I love that movie Airheads and you know
I and I'll tell you why I go back and
really appreciate that and AirHeads by
the way it had a radio theme you guys
were in a rock band you and Sandler are
in a rock band you're a big influence
for that movie was I really absolutely
are you kidding no no that was lost on
us well well well you guys invaded and
took over a radio station in order to
get your band played on the radio that
was the premise yeah when I think about
that movie and Chris Farley was in it
yeah and I think Chris yeah Chris Farley
you know I go back and watch his old
Saturday Night Live bits and and when
his appearance is on Letterman I mean
that guy and and in your movie he was
playing AirHeads he's playing a cop
and just those little facial ticks those
little moments where his boss is the
head cop is yelling at you it's so
[__] brilliant and and what is it
it's was it because Farley would just
commit to the characters I think because
he and Sandler how he's had a like not a
rivalry but a competition going on to
see who could crack each other up the
best and so
one night we were sitting there in
Sanders sitting next to Farley and
Farley looks over at Sandler and Sandler
he wears shorts basketball shorts all
the time and he pulls his shorts up and
he's yanked his nut sacked out on his
thigh so just so a piece of his scrot is
sticking out and he points at it and he
goes I got this growth
Marley's like it looks like it itches
he's like I know is there a paste or
something for this and these guys would
do this [__] with each other just to see
who would corpse first and that was
always going on and I think it's because
I know when they became writing partners
of this and now that they had a pact
going which was
um I'm not going to be afraid and you
don't be afraid I won't be afraid we'll
go forward together with courage you
know and and that's really what they did
and I think it comedy with little I know
that I'm not a comedian is really about
confidence you have to right really own
what you're doing you got to know what
you're doing did that movie make a lot
of money Aaron no or no it wasn't
successful it was a studio like yeah you
know they they didn't really like it
that much they didn't Steve Buscemi had
a t-shirt on for the first three days
that said blow me
and and the studio in the studio saw the
dailies and they were like ah no you
know and they they changed the shirt but
the movie takes place in one day so like
when would Rex go and change his shirt
he doesn't but you just noticed that the
blow me shirt's gone because that was
just that was too spicy
foreign